Narrator:
This is the Shark Tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes of getting
an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
Vroom!
Narrator: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for...
voila !
...or they'll walk away
with nothing.
What kind of sales
do you have?
None.
Pre-revenue.
Wrong answer.
It's that moment
when I say you're dead to me.
Narrator: If the sharks
hear a great idea...
if we had not saved up,
I wouldn't have taken a leap
to become an entrepreneur.
You are going to become legend.
Narrator: ...they're ready
to invest using their own money.
I made you a generous offer
for you and for me.
Narrator: And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
$700,000
for a 10% interest rate.
You might as Well
just go out of business now.
You don't live
in the real world.
I can pay you back.
I'm out!
Whoa!
NARRATOR:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-Made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Daymond John is a fashion
and branding expert,
who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu,
with over $6 billion
in retail sales to date.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents,
and has launched
over 300 products
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban -- Notorious
billionaire entrepreneur,
tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank
is a product to ensure
you always know
who's at your front door.
[ knock on door ]
Who's there?
It's Jamie,
here to pitch.
Who?
It's Jamie.
Come in.
Sharks,
wouldn't it have been nice
to know who was behind the door
before you let me in?
With my product, you can.
My name is Jamie Siminoff.
I'm from los Angeles,
california.
My product is the doorbot.
I'm seeking $700,000
for a 10% stake in the company.
Consumers are currently spending
billions of dollars
outfitting their homes
with products
that work with Smartphones.
However, one of the most
ubiquitous technologies,
the doorbell, has not changed
since it was invented in 1880,
until now.
Introducing the doorbot --
The first-ever video doorbell
built for the smartphone.
With doorbot,
you can see and speak
with visitors from anywhere.
But I didn't invent doorbot
just to make our lives
more convenient.
It also adds needed security.
Let me show you.
Mark, let's just say this is
your house in Dallas.
You'll see on the screen here
that I'm projecting the doorbot
app for my smartphone
to make it easier
to see the demo.
Now, just like a regular call,
when someone rings
the doorbot...
[ Doorbell rings ]
...you can see them and decline
if it's someone
that you don't want to talk to
or accept and say hello
to your Visitor.
Think of it as caller I.D.
for your front door.
[ laughs ]
[ doorbell rings ]
Herjavec: Aah!
Cuban: Aah!
[ Laughter ]
O'Leary: Hey,
good-looking doorbot guy.
Hey, Mark.
It's your good friend,
Mr. Wonderful.
I wanted to have you join me
on this deal with doorbot.
I think we can get them to go
all royalties and no equity.
[ laughter ]
Mark, we know
that no real entrepreneur
is gonna accept that deal,
and now you can tell
Mr. Wonderful to scram.
And the best thing is,
you can do it
without having to be
face-to-face with him.
Now, sharks,
join me,
and the next time you hear...
[ Doorbell rings ]
...it'll be...
[ Cash register dings ]
now, who wants to be first
to ring my bell?
Jamie,
what if you hit "Accept"?
then what happens?
If you hit "Accept,"
then the light goes blue,
and then
you can talk to them.
So, your voice
comes out of it.
Your voice comes out of it.
It's got a microphone
and speakers.
Like a speaker.
So it's two-way audio,
one-way video.
If someone came up and said,
"Mm. Eyeball there,"
can they just take it off?
Because all burglars
ring the doorbell first.
[ laughter ]
You know what, though, Mark?
That's actually true.
Burglars are not usually
violent criminals.
They want to see
if someone's home.
They want the opportunity
to go into a house that's not --
that does not have
people in it.
So it's actually true.
People do ring the doorbell.
It's very hard to remove,
and we also have offered
that any customer
that has one stolen,
we will replace it
for free of charge.
And how much do each one
of these units sell for?
$199.
What are your costs
to make it?
$81.83 is our cost
landed in our warehouse
in the United States.
And do you sell it
to retailers?
So far, we've only sold direct
on our own online store.
We are launching with our first
retailer in november,
which is Staples.
We launched nine months ago.
We've done an aggregate a
million dollars in sales so far.
Good for you.
And in the last --
in the last --
You've done a million dollars
so far? Wow.
In the last month,
we've done $250,000 in sales.
Our sales have grown
month over month.
All online, Jamie?
All online, all direct.
Do you have
any competitors?
Currently, we do not have
any direct competitors.
When I say direct,
we are the first video doorbell
built for the smartphone.
Now, there are other
video doorbells out there
that go to a -- a panel.
It's not two-way, so you don't
have communication from that.
You can just see
who's there, which now --
How much
does your competition cost?
The lowest-price camera
would be, you know, $50 to $100,
up to thousands of dollars
for some of these systems.
But we're not trying to compete
with the $100,000 systems
that integrate cameras
and everything in your home.
That's -- that -- that, to me,
is a totally different market.
It's for someone
who doesn't have it.
What we're trying to do
is disrupt that market
to give that to everybody,
the nor-- to give it
to my wife, who's at home,
who's in the bedroom
with my 5-year-old.
I'm away, and at 8:00 at night
and it's dark out,
someone knocks on the door.
I like the product,
but are there bigger solutions
that can come in and kind of
push this out the door?
This category will exist.
I mean,
the doorbell will stay there.
It doesn't get trumped
by technology.
We'll drive that change.
See, I think there's a --
there's a thousand different
ways to alert.
What business is not gonna get
replaced by future technology?
But here's the problem --
It's -- It's about
being able to be nimble
and actually be part
of that change.
Amen.
Greiner:
I'm gonna jump in here.
I think that you have potential
to do a lot more with this,
but I'm not connecting to
that this does enough
at this time
to distinguish itself
as different from what else
is out there on the market
for the higher price point,
and so, for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
We're not comparing ourselves
to a -- a --
a cheap video doorbell
that has a little,
tiny little panel.
No one's arguing the quality
of the product. I like it.
I think you're gonna do great
with it.
But I've got to be able to say,
you know what?
When I jump in,
I've got to add enough value
that this company, instead
of being worth $7 million,
could be worth $80 million,
$90 million.
I just don't see
that progression.
But --
and for that reason,
I'm out.
When I --
When I look at businesses,
I look at the three tiers
that it could hit --
a luxury, mid-Tier,
and lower tier.
And obviously,
we understand the luxury market,
where we have the $20,000
and $30,000 systems
and all that type of stuff.
That's not for that.
The mid-Tier
is the adts of the world
that most likely
Will just add this
to their services
in some sense.
I-I'm wrestling over
where this goes in the market.
I just don't think
it's for me. I'm out.
Personally,
I'm a security guy,
so the idea of having
another access point
on my house like that
freaks me out a little bit
'cause all those --
Adt and all those other ones --
are hardwired.
I can't hack into those,
right?
So I think you've priced
a lot of value into it,
but I think my real struggle
with it is,
it's really not
an internet play.
It's a consumer device.
But you're pricing it
at $199.
That -- that price point is
gonna start dropping quickly
as your volumes go up.
For that reason, I'm out.
All right.
Well, sorry about that.
Don't send him
to my house!
[ laughter ]
It's just --
It's just you and you now.
Jamie, let's take stock
of what's happened here.
You made a few jokes
about Mr. Wonderful
at the beginning
and about the royalty structure.
Am I gonna regret that,
Mr. Wonderful?
Narrator:
Four sharks are out.
Kevin is Jamie's last chance
at a deal.
Jamie, let's take stock
of what's happened here.
You made a few jokes
about Mr. Wonderful
at the beginning
and about the royalty structure.
Am I gonna regret that,
Mr. Wonderful?
The only person left
is Mr. Wonderful.
I'll make you an offer.
I'll give you $700,000.
I want a 10% royalty.
That drops down to 7%
after I recoup the $700,000,
and I get 5% of the company's
equity today.
You know, we -- we have a --
a vision, I think,
to build a -- a big company
out of this,
and I can't give 10% --
someone 10% of all of our sales
'cause it'll bleed us of cash
while we really need it
the most.
I'm basically providing you
factoring capital.
You need my $700,000
for inventory.
But -- But, respectfully,
I can raise that money
through venture debt or line
of credit or something else,
so that's not the kind of
money that I'm looking for.
Then why don't you --
Then why don't you counter me
with a venture-Debt offer?
So, I would do $700,000
for a 10% interest rate
with a 3% equity kicker.
No, I'm not interested.
That doesn't -- it --
It's not -- doesn't --
It's not commensurate
with the risk I'm taking.
Honestly,
I do appreciate the offer,
but at the same time,
that money that you would be
taking on the royalty
I need to reinvest
back in this business.
What's the difference between
the interest and the royalty?
The interest is cheaper.
Yeah.
The interest
I can get rid of.
O'Leary: You can get --
I can pay you back.
Oh, so you don't like the -- The
royalty-In-perpetuity aspect?
Absolutely.
But I took the risk
up front.
I believed in you -- the only
shark, I might add, that did.
$700,000's a lot of money
up front.
It is a lot of money.
Absolutely.
That's --
That's a lot of money.
Okay, Jamie.
It's that moment
when I say you're dead to me
because you don't want to take
my offer.
I made you a very valid offer,
I think,
under the circumstances.
Respectfully, Mr. Wonderful,
we're gonna decline.
Go kick some ass, Jamie.
Thank you very much.
Good luck, Jamie.
Yeah, good luck.
Herjavec: Good luck.
Siminoff: Thanks, sharks.
Kevin, he was, uh --
I'm surprised.
He was w-wavering.
There was a moment where he
actually considered it.
I would have done that deal.
Whatever happened
to peeking through the window
and saying, "Go away"?
[ laughs ]
SIMINOFF: Mr. Wonderful
gave us an offer
for just royalties
on the company,
and I don't believe
you can build a big company
having one person take 10%
of the sales for life.
Welcome to Fire Island.
How do you like it here?
[ cheers and applause ]
Every year, I take
my most successful
"Shark Tank" Entrepreneurs
for a weekend retreat
in my summer home
in Fire Island.
This year, I've invited
Cousins maine lobster,
villy's customs,
Tom+Chee, Ryan's barkery,
Daisy cakes, the Coop,
and ride-on carry-on.
It's my way of discussing
a little business,
having a lot of fun,
and rewarding my entrepreneurs.
I've got a gift
for everybody here
that's gonna be
your bedtime reading tonight.
It's the new "Shark Tank" Book.
Every week,
millions of americans tune in
to watch "Shark Tank,"
and we never expected to inspire
so many hopeful entrepreneurs.
So we decided
to write a book about it.
All the sharks contributed
with their best ideas
on how to build a business
and make your dream come true.
[ cheering ]
These are my favorite
entrepreneurs for one reason --
they're making me money.
Our sales have increased
by $600,000.
A million dollars in Sales
and still climbing.
We have done $2.5 million
in sales in one year.
Corcoran:
These seven small businesses
Have created
over 150 new American jobs.
It's just what we need
in this country,
and I'm so proud
to be a part of that.
To the best entrepreneurs
in the whole universe.
[ cheering ]
I'm not here just to share
business expertise.
I'm here to inspire them,
believe in them,
and push them on their way.
Boydstun:
Barbara has been incredible.
She makes us think bigger
and better.
Quackenbush:
It's been an awesome time
to meet all
the other entrepreneurs
and really get new advice
about what we're doing right
and what we're doing wrong.
Lenz: We're all learning
from each other,
so it's been
a phenomenal couple days.
We love you, Barb.
Mwah!
ALL:
Thank you, beautiful Barbara!
[ Cheering ]
NARRATOR: Next into the tank
is an entrepreneur
from Cramerton, North Carolina,
with a unique alternative
to conventional condiments.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Julie Busha,
and my product is slawsa.
I'm seeking
a $150,000 investment
for 15% of my company.
Tell me, when was the last time
you were at a grilling
or tailgating event
and someone actually
complimented the host or
hostess on their condiments?
Well, it probably never happened
because -- Let's face it --
traditional Condiments
are Boring,
and they haven't changed
in decades.
But what if I said I had
the condiment
that will change your lives?
Introducing slawsa,
a unique cross
between a slaw and a salsa.
It's great
on your grilling fare,
like your hot dogs,
brats, burgers.
Use it as a sandwich spread
or even as a dip
for tortilla chips.
Right now I'd like for you
all to taste slawsa
and how truly slaw-some
it is.
[ laughs ] It's slaw-Some.
It's slaw-Some. Yeah.
Now, we have four flavors.
For the garlic lovers
like Robert,
we have a garlic
and a garlic spicy.
Thank you.
We have the original
and the spicy as well.
Taste it a little bit before you
decide what you want to put
on your hot dogs
or your brats.
Thank you.
This is sauerkraut mixed
with mustard mixed with...
this is a cross between
a slaw -- So cabbage --
and a salsa, so there are
some heat undertones.
What are your sales?
Uh, well,
let me tell you --
over 4,200 stores nationwide
so far
in just over
a year and a half.
Really?
Wow.
Year -- Sales for year one
is $212,000.
Sales for the finish
out of year two
is projected to be
$500,000.
Wow!
Good for you.
Whoa.
And what stores
are you in?
Major retailers.
We're in 1,500 Kroger's.
We're in all
Publix stores. We're --
Wow.
Julie -- Julie, how did you get
these stores?
Um, I go myself.
I am extremely aggressive.
[ laughs ] Good job.
How did you get started
in the business?
Um, it -- it is based
off of an old family recipe
of a former partner of mine
who I just recently bought out
to be a part of it.
So, you bought into
an existing company.
How much did you pay in?
About $50,000 total.
Tell me if I understand this
correctly.
Yes.
So, there's relish.
There's mustard relish.
There's sweet relish.
There's some garlic relish.
There's hot relish.
Right.
But those have been
pretty much on the shelves...
right.
...for the past 10, 15,
20 years, right?
Right. Right.
What you've done is come in
and say, "I'm extending
the flavor base."
There is nothing like this
out there.
Well, exactly, right?
Right, right.
You're -- You've -- You've
created a new category.
John: Category.
This is a cabbage-based --
Herjavec:
Julie, what does it cost
compared to a standard
relish bottle?
Um, well, it is gonna be
about 20% higher,
and let me tell you why.
Because a pickle relish
is basically vinegar.
O'Leary: Right.
And -- and it's a brine.
Ours is a hot-fill process,
so it is a little bit more
labor-Intensive.
So, you have a co-packer
doing this for you?
Yes.
Tell me what it costs you to
make it, what you sell it for.
It -- all the flavors right now
is $1.25.
Okay,
and you sell it for?
$2.25.
And can you tell me,
based on the buyout
of your partner,
if you're paying that person
a royalty at all?
I am.
Comes out to about .66%
to any-- to up to
a little bit over 2%.
Is there a limit to it?
There is a limit.
It is not perpetuity.
What are you gonna use
$150,000 for?
Because of the buyout --
and that is my responsibility.
I am not putting that
against the company.
That's not on the books.
Right.
That is not on the books.
It comes out of your profits,
or how do you --
No, it comes out
of my personal savings.
My husband and I have been
extremely...
...fiscally responsible.
We graduated college debt-free
because we earned scholarships.
When it came time
to buy our first house...
we bought a house
half of what we were --
The lender approved us to buy.
We've never paid a penny
of credit-Card interest
in our lives because we don't
live beyond our means.
If we had not saved up,
I wouldn't have taken the leap
to become an entrepreneur.
So that's my responsibility --
Is -- Is -- is the buyout.
I would like the money
for increased production
because I know the $50,000
I have in there
is only gonna last so long
because we are expanding
rapidly.
Are you currently
taking a salary?
I am not.
And I'm okay doing that
for a couple years,
of not --
Not taking a salary.
For a couple years?
You're gonna work --
How are you living?
Yeah, how are you living?
My husband and I saved
a -- a good amount of money.
Good for you.
Julie,
I love what you're doing,
setting an example
for people around the country,
around the world --
Give up a little bit,
save your money...
Yeah.
...and put yourself
in an amazing position
to be successful.
Yes.
You're an example
like we rarely have in here.
Thank you.
I wish I could do more for you.
You know, I love it.
I'll be a customer.
I'll Slawsa-Cize a lot,
but it's not really --
I'd like to get
in those stadiums, Mark.
But that's not enough for me
to do an investment.
I'm out.
All right.
Julie, here --
Here's what
I've learned about you
in the short time
we've spent together.
Okay.
You're
one tough cookie.
Okay.
Right? I mean --
That's a compliment.
You know, you set yourself up
for success.
But I find it
too sweet.
Okay.
J-Just me,
personally...
right.
...I like really,
really spicy mustard.
And we can go
with the spicier flavor.
I wish you all the best,
but I'm out.
Okay.
I would like to have a partner
because I've never scaled
a business
the way I need to scale this.
I'm not gonna need
my hand held,
and I'm haven't needed
my hand held for several years.
Well, I tasted the product,
and my opinion
in regards to the taste
of the product doesn't matter
because your sales
proves me wrong.
But if I'm not excited
about the product,
it's really hard
for me to get behind it.
Well, that's a shame.
I'm out.
You know,
I think you've done amazing.
The fact that you got
into Kroger --
1,500 stores --
is amazing.
And the fact that you sold well
Incredible.
But I, personally,
don't want to be
in the Slawsa business.
Okay.
I think it's a great product,
though.
I'm out.
Kevin,
you like to make money.
Yeah.
Cuban: Yeah.
How -- How can we sell
over 200,000 jars
with Very little marketing
in less than two years' time?
Very admirable.
No question.
I see your passion,
but 15% stake...
...you're actually not
worth that right now.
But rather than beat you up
on your valuation --
Can I -- I would
like to tell you why I'm
worth a million dollars.
Why?
To go from $212,000
to $500,000,
it would be
not very wise of me
to not project
my next year's sales
as closer to my valuation.
But think about the risk
for an investor.
Risk?
For that kind
of valuation,
it doesn't reflect the risk
in a one-woman business.
You could walk out
of the Shark Tank tonight
and get run over by a bus,
and that's the end
of this company.
Well, that's why
you would have
a-an insurance policy
on me.
[ laughs ]
Yeah, but that -- That --
then, if I do that,
I'll want to run you over
with a bus.
Right.
[ laughter ]
It's a better return.
That's what I was thinking.
I-I appreciate
the presentation,
but it's not gonna happen
for me today.
I'm out.
Okay, well --
Cuban:
Congratulations, Julie.
You have
an amazing business.
No, I-I appreciate
all of your time,
and, um -- and I will make
all of you regret this,
happily, So, thank you.
I hope you do.
Keep on going.
Thank you so very much.
All right.
Thank you.
You know what?
The fact that she scrimped,
had no debt...
fantastic.
...pays off
all her credit cards,
saved up enough money
to invest in this other
company and buy them out,
is -- Is just such an amazing
example for everybody.
[ voice breaking ] Greatness
does not come without sacrifice.
I'm taking a risk,
and I've done that,
and -- and it will happen.
Narrator:
Next up are entrepreneurs
from Detroit, Michigan,
with a way to enhance
the sharing
of your favorite images.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Trevor George.
I'm Blake George.
And I'm Sanford Nelson.
And our company is called
magic moments.
We're looking to raise $500,000
for a 15% equity stake
in our company.
Millions of people take photos
on their cellphones every day.
Magic moments allows you
to take those photos
and create customized products
right from your mobile phone.
The key difference
is that magic moments
lets you create these products
on the go.
No longer do you have to take
your portable camera
and find that cord
and hook it up to your computer.
No one wants to deal
with that hassle.
Magic moments
solves that problem.
But wait. There's more.
For the first time ever,
you can make money
off the products you create.
Simply upload your magic moment
to our marketplace,
share it, sell,
and make money.
So, how does it work?
Well, sharks,
it's as easy as one, two, three.
First, you take a photo,
like this.
Then, simply upload your photo
to the magic moments app,
choose a product, customize it
in our design center,
and voila !
Your magic moments
is ready for purchase.
And it's not just t-shirts.
We offer iphone cases, mugs,
mouse pads, coasters,
canvas bags,
and hundreds of other products.
There's a couple phone apps
that allow you
to upload a picture
or make a t-shirt.
More than a couple.
Absolutely.
But there are none that allow
you to sell the products.
What do you mean,
sell them?
We are the first --
sell them.
So, I take a picture
of the eiffel tower
or a beautiful landscape
of detroit --
because that's
where we're from --
or maybe the fall colors
that no one will ever forget.
Do you have any evidence
that you can get people
to take uncopyrighted images
and sell them to someone else
on your site?
Absolutely.
Give me the numbers.
There are no numbers,
necessarily.
Oh! Don't you hate it
when that happens?
Herjavec: So, Trevor,
your premise is,
I take a picture of Lori,
and not only do I want --
want it on my coffee cup --
'Cause I love Lori --
[ Laughs ] Thank you.
But I'm gonna put it
on your site,
and everybody in the world
is gonna buy that coffee mug?
That's until Lori sues
you into the stone age
for using her image
for commerce.
There is an entire community
of -- of what -- What they call
iphonographers,
or amateur photographers.
Yes.
It's like everyone has become
a photographer these days.
You should see the pictures.
It's absolutely beautiful.
Do -- do you not think that
if I take pictures of you,
your kids,
or something else like that --
You don't think that
I'm gonna have a challenge
out there in the market
if I sell it?
Intellectual property.
- Copyright infringement
laws-
--I mean
It's a serious issue
right?
We've secured
an exclusive relationship
with a public company --
cafepress.
They're our back-end
manufacturers...
there you go.
...which means we have
global distribution.
Every image
that a user would take,
whether it's to buy
or to sell,
gets passed through
cafepress' legal team,
and they approve and deny
each one
based on a set of criteria.
Who do you think, though,
is going to be utilizing
the salable part
of this?
Well, there -- there --
There's two sides of it.
There's the personalized side --
The families, the weddings,
the dogs,
things like that.
Herjavec: Okay, Trevor.
I don't get it.
I take a picture of my dog.
Nobody knows it's my dog.
Right.
I put it online.
Who's gonna buy that picture?
No one's gonna buy that.
[ laughter ]
No one's gonna buy
a picture of your dog
because that's not
a great picture that
everyone wants to buy.
So, what am I missing?
That there's scenery
of -- of Los Angeles.
There's --
There's a -- a beach.
Why wouldn't they just go
to cafepress?
Well, we are --
We are cafepress' mobile app.
So, let's make that clear.
So they can only deal with you
on mobile -- Nobody else?
Nelson: Correct.
Blake:
Vendor-Specific, yeah.
Mobile for -- for create and buy
and create and sell.
We are cafepress' mobile app.
Cuban:
And what kind of deal
did you have to do to get them
to go exclusively with you?
We did a --
We did a licensing deal.
It's
an exclusive relationship.
We're their techno-- Technology
mobile arm.
What kind of sales
do you have?
None.
Pre-revenue.
Sure. Sure.
Herjavec: Ohh.
Goose egg.
Did -- Did they take revenue
in your company...
No.
...or is it a straight
royalty deal?
It's a straight
royalty deal.
Blake: Yeah.
Why would they do an exclusive
deal with you guys?
When we went to make
the exclusive deal to them,
we had the technology built.
And all we had to do
was take our technology
and map it into cafepress.
Tell me what's unique
about the technology.
Well, we're wrapped
right into cafepress,
And you can create
and Buy everything
from the mobile phone.
But anybody can do that.
Not everyone can do that.
There's really only three
companies that can do that --
There's cafepress, zazzle,
and shutterfly.
John: Okay, guys.
$500,000, 15%,
you value your company
a little bit over $3 million.
You have not made
any sales yet.
Sure.
Okay.
I'm gonna
smell this out here.
That means you are
probably already in a
money-raise situation.
Correct.
You've already
taken in funding.
We're family and friends,
still.
Family and friends.
How much?
$500,000.
How much did they get
for that percentage?
33%.
You've already
raised this.
Correct.
One of the tests I do
as a -- as a tech investor is,
I look at this and say
you've put a value
of over $3 million
for me to enter
to give you $500,000
for 15%.
I can emulate
the same thing for --
I don't know --
$300,000, $400,000.
I'm -- I'm sorry.
I don't buy your premise,
and I don't buy your valuation.
I'm out.
Fair enough.
Yep.
I think you guys need
to consider
the upside
of this massive market
and think about the fact that
this little device right here
that sits in the pocket of
hundreds of millions of people
around the world --
This is the content-creation
device of the future.
You're the first guy to ever say
that in "Shark Tank."
If I take a picture
of my cute puppy
and my goal
is to make revenue,
you don't think
I'm gonna take the time
to just transfer that
over to my P.C.
Or do something web-based,
because I --
not if you could do it all
with -- right here.
It's a whole lot easier
to do it
on a web-based interface.
I'm not doing it off my mobile
phone 'cause it's a hassle.
Because you want to maximize
your revenue,
you're -- You're not gonna care
if it's mobile.
I'm out.
Daymond, you're a branding guy,
right?
We're talking about
magic moments here.
I mean, we have a tradeMark
on the name.
That's a massive name.
In any language,
someone would understand
the name magic moments.
Magic moments --
That could be anything.
That could be, uh, viagra,
a laxative -- Anything.
[ laughter ]
until you have proof of concept
in sales And you can show it,
you're only making up
an opinion, and it's not a fact.
I think you're
missing the boat
because cafepress
is our proof of concept.
Then I'm gonna have
to miss the Boat.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
I'm out.
Look, we know
that we have
a robust system
that works, okay?
And we're businessmen,
so if you guys like the concept,
you know, make us an offer,
and we can negotiate.
Why would somebody
want to buy the pictures
that other people take?
Everybody can do it.
I'm out.
You know, I think what you've
really defined --
If I understand it correctly --
That's unique
is the immediacy.
I don't think you've proven
that the marketplace
actually exists,
so that's my challenge
with the entire premise.
I don't see the immediacy
being the -- the real pearl
in this entire deal.
I'm out.
Okay.
The immediacy --
When we launched,
we were the first ones
out there.
We're still the only app that
allows you to sell products.
I mean, this is a --
this is a massive market.
Cafepress --
$300 million business.
Guys, that's great,
but Everybody's out.
You're done in here.
Thank you.
Thanks, sharks.
The sharks missed
their opportunity now,
but that's okay
because when they
want in, they're gonna
have to pay a lot more.
I can't wait to give them
that valuation.
Ooh!
I'm Rosy.
This is my sister, Donna.
We live in Washington, D.C.,
and we are the creators
of surprise ride.
We come from
a family of six.
We escaped war from Lebanon
and emigrated to Canada.
Donna: Growing up,
we really didn't have much,
but our parents told us
that anything is possible.
I wanted to go to school
at harvard,
and I was able to go there
many years later.
Rosy wanted to travel the world.
She got to study abroad.
And even though
We didn't have much,
we made the best
out of that situation.
Safety first.
Too often, we hear kids
complaining that they're bored,
and moms struggle
to keep their kids
with short attention spans
busy.
Our product helps families spend
fun, quality time together,
and it helps parents and kids
gain knowledge along the way.
We've risked a lot
to make this dream come true.
I gave up a great career
on wall street.
We've both refused
great job offers
to make this dream
come true.
We validated that we have
a great product.
People absolutely love
the experience,
but we need capital
from the sharks
to share the ride
with America.
Hi, I'm Donna Khalife.
I'm Rosy Khalife.
Both: We're the sisters behind
the company surprise ride.
Today we're raising
$110,000
in exchange for 10%
of our company.
Surprise ride
is a monthly bundle of adventure
that gets kids excited
about learning.
With surprise ride, every month,
kids receive a surprise box
of interactive activities
and all the supplies they need
to explore a new topic.
We work with experts
to curate activities
of the highest quality.
Families everywhere
want to give their kids
a good reason
to put away the video games
and explore the world
through hands-on play.
Surprise ride makes it easier
than ever before.
Sharks, we actually picked up
some of your mail today,
and your surprise rides
have arrived.
Yes! Goodies!
I love the boxes.
Thank you.
Beautiful packaging.
Oh, wow!
Oh, Robert.
Will you stop?
Look, Daymond.
It's car racing.
You always act so amazed
by everything you see.
Robert, you're gonna get
to design and model a racecar.
Vroom!
Lori,
we know that you love cooking,
and who doesn't love
chocolate?
Right.
You're gonna get to make
chocolate from Scratch
and also design your very own
brand of chocolates.
Great.
Kevin, we know that you love
photography,
so you're gonna get
a solar kit
that has you taking pictures
using the power of the sun.
Thank you.
Love it.
Daymond, we heard
that you love to travel,
so you are gonna be entering
an adventure
into the exciting city
of Barcelona.
All right.
So, you're gonna be designing
a mosaic
in the style of world-renowned
architect Gaudi
and exploring the fashion
in barcelona.
I like.
And you heard
I like to get fat?
Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
We heard that you love --
We -- we -- we --
we might have heard
that you love basketball,
so we designed
a basketball-themed ride
that has you creating
a mini basketball game
for your desk.
And then get fat.
What's a good game
without some popcorn?
I got that.
This is really cute.
I mean, I have to say, this is
an extremely well-constructed
quality surprise box.
Well, first of all,
thank you very much.
Very, very cool.
How much do they sell for?
It starts at $24.99
for a 6-Month or a 12-Month
subscription.
And that's per month. Right.
Per month. Yep.
And it's $29.99 if you buy it
on a monthly basis.
What are your sales?
So, so far,
we've shipped almost 800 boxes,
and we've got over 220
active members.
That's just in the last
four months.
Oh, okay.
Four months,
so you just started.
Oh.
O'Leary: Ladies,
you know in an online business,
when someone comes
into the Shark Tank
with a model like this,
the two questions
that always get asked,
and hopefully,
you're gonna know this answer --
What is your
customer-acquisition cost,
and what is the value of that
customer in profit margin?
So, our customer-acquisition
cost is $5.30.
What's the value of that
customer for 12 months?
So, for just a 12-Month period,
it's a $130 customer value.
Usually,
when Mr. O'Leary
asks the client-acquisition
question,
there's a lot
of deer-in-the-headlight,
but what a great answer.
I got to know
your background.
My background
is on Wall Street.
I actually worked
in mergers and acquisitions
for a number of years.
Ahh.
Then I left that and went back
to get my MBA at Harvard,
fell in love
with Social entrepreneurship.
You have a Harvard MBA?
Good for you.
O'Leary:
What about your sister?
I have a degree
in marketing,
so I have
a business background.
I've worked with a number
of lifestyle brands
and even some kid brands,
so --
What does it cost you
to make each box,
and where are you
making these?
We're at a 50% margin,
and that 50% goes towards
buying our merchandise,
shipping, and fulfillment.
We have a fulfillment center
in Florida
that assembles
all the boxes
and ships them
out to our customers.
Can they scale?
Absolutely.
Donna: They can.
So -- So, my business-School
background basically forced us
from day 1 to create a business
that's scalable.
Greiner:
One of the concerns --
and I say this often
to new entrepreneurs --
is don't invest too much
before you have the sales.
Absolutely.
We actually --
So, how much have you invested
in that is in that warehouse?
This business model
really allows us
to anticipate
the demand very close
to when we need to order
that inventory,
which is terrific, so we have
very little inventory.
Because they're
multi-Month orders.
Right.
We can actually estimate
how many orders
we're having
and --
And order accordingly.
And, I'd like to add,
we've raised $100,000
from a very well-known
tech investor --
Irwin Jacobs, who's the founder
of Qualcomm.
How much equity
did he get?
He's actually
an -- An Angel investor
in the form
of a convertible note.
So, you know darn well
that $100,000 from Irwin
and $110,000 from us ain't squat
for a subscription business.
The -- the capital
that we're raising now
gets us through
the next 12 months.
Are you sure?
Yes, and the rea--
Because in
a subscription-based business --
You know how many have
gone out of business.
Yes. We're familiar
with that.
Right?
And what's the projection
for next year, Donna?
For next year, we're
anticipating about
$500,000 in sales,
and that's
on the low end --
How many subscribers
is that?
That's 3,500.
Look, you don't have
enough money to get
to $500,000 in sales.
John: But they might
because they have access
to this other investor.
So if you have this --
I didn't get to answer
your question earlier,
but Daymond, effectively,
is doing that, which is that --
if you have this other investor,
why are you here?
Irwin invested in us.
He's a big fan
of this mission,
which is to bring curiosity
to children all over the world.
Cuban: There you just hit
the nail on the head.
There's a difference
between a mission
and having a fully thought-out,
fully funded business
that is gonna accomplish
a specific goal.
I -- so, let me tell you
a little bit
about how we plan
to spend that money.
That might give you
some comfort.
Two things we're doing --
Driving traffic to the website
and then monetizing
that traffic.
Okay, that's easy to say.
Explain.
So, the first thing is,
we've partnered with a
marketing agency,
the leading expert
on reaching moms.
What does that cost you
monthly?
It's gonna cost us $40,000 total
for the next 12 months
to reach 5 million
to 10 million moms.
John: Donna and Rosy,
I want to make sure
I heard the facts correct.
I think you said you did
800 boxes
and you have 220 members.
Would that come
to around $25,000?
Yeah, about $23,000,
$25,000.
Herjavec: It's a startup.
It's a brand-new startup.
I got it, but the startup
question here is,
you would like $110,000
for 10%.
Yep.
Yes.
So the value of the company
at $1.1 million?
Yeah.
You're an investment banker,
or at least you were one.
Do you think there's a little
extreme ask in terms of value?
So, of course, the -- the --
the classic valuation question.
This is literally
what I spent...
yes, it is
the classic question.
...every -- Every minute --
Every minute of my hours on...
Cuban:
I love that answer.
...in investment banking.
And now you have
to defend it.
We know
there are two things
that primarily go
into a valuation --
the team and the future earning
potential of this company.
This team has been working
together for over 20 years.
We work so well together.
When you say you've been
working together for 20 years,
can you explain that?
By that, I mean
we've been sisters.
Herjavec: I don't know
if that's a good thing.
I have two daughters.
They're ready
to kill each other...
Yeah.
...if they spend too much time
with each other.
We hear that a lot,
but we --
we came from Lebanon, actually,
as war refugees,
and we lived in a one-bedroom
apartment when We were kids.
We didn't have a lot
of video games and Toys
and things
to entertain ourselves,
but fortunately, our dad always
encouraged us to experiment,
try a lot
of different things.
We sort of had a crafts
store and a -- a chemistry
lab in our living room.
In our basement, Yeah.
Um, I'm a really simple
and basic guy.
When I started fubu,
I sold 800 shirts.
You know what I was worth?
I was worth 800 shirts.
You're valuing the company
at $1.1 million.
I'm out.
See, I don't quite agree
with you.
And we can debate this
till the cows come home.
My guess is,
you're gonna need
somewhere between $3 million
and $5 million
to scale this to where you have
a sustainable business.
I went to school with the girls
who founded birchbox,
which is one
of the most successful
subscription services.
Mm-hmm.
They've hit
300,000 subscribers.
But, you know, you're at a proof
of concept right now,
in my opinion.
I'm tempted,
but I'm gonna pass.
I'm out.
Okay.
Donna, let -- Let --
Let me tell you where I'm at.
Yeah.
It's a great idea,
but there's a lot
of executional risk here.
You know,
your idea of spending $40,000
to get that traffic
is a little unrealistic.
I think you're underestimating
the hustle
that this business is gonna take
to get off the ground.
But I think
you'll figure it out.
So here's my offer to you.
Narrator: Two sharks are out,
but Robert has an offer.
So, my offer is the offer
that I feel comfortable with
that reflects the executional
risk in the business.
I'll give you the $110,000
for 25%.
Lori, Mark, any other?
You were asked what were you
going to do with the $100,000.
You said $40,000
to a marketing company.
What was the rest?
What were you --
Optimizing,
monetizing that traffic
so that we can actually generate
the sales.
I think that this is
one of the finest and best-Made
gift boxes for kids
that I've ever seen.
I love it.
I know what it's like
to be a woman in business.
And I know that sometimes
it can be Harder,
but I also know that you
can make anything happen
if you put your mind to it.
I had to start
from the ground up by myself,
and I had to figure out
a lot of things,
but it was the best learning
lessons I could have ever had.
And when I look
at the two of you,
you make me think of myself,
and I think
that you can do this --
She's telling you she's
out, in like 9,000 words,
7 paragraphs.
And -- don't be rude.
Donna: Lori,
you know how to reach women.
You know how to reach moms.
You know how to reach aunts.
Doing it on your own --
That's how you're
really going to learn.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Rosy: Lori, no.
I'm giving you
my very best advice
because that's what I think
is important here.
Lori, we need you.
Herjavec:
Donna, she's out.
To address
your theory question --
You don't have to address
anything.
Okay, cool.
I made you an offer.
Mark?
Either say yes or no.
Cuban: Let me --
Let me ask some questions.
What's your core competency?
Our core competency
is execution.
That's what I was
gonna tell you, Robert.
Wrong answer.
I'm in talk with experts,
professors --
Worst possible answer.
Worst possible answer?
Worst possible.
Come on.
The fact that you need
to go out and get
this marketing company,
you need to go out and get
this optimization company,
you need to go out
in these other companies,
means you don't have
that road to success
directly in your mind.
When you're an entrepreneur,
you've got to be able
to control your own destiny
on a number of things.
I asked you the question.
What's your core competency?
I thought you were asking me
personally, so my --
Oh, come on, now. Come on.
I-I-I'm serious.
That's a Harvard answer.
That's not a real answer.
Oh, come on.
Okay, that's fair,
but let me
tell you something.
I'm out.
This was why my offer
was so high.
You don't live
in the real world.
You live in the world
of theory.
Ladies,
this isn't kansas anymore.
I made you a generous offer
for you and for me
because I can help you.
I disagree with her.
You need guidance
along the way.
Are you staying in?
Will you do 20%?
I'm out.
I'm out!
O'Leary: Whoa!
Whoa, Robert. Whoa.
You gave me time
to change my mind.
I --
Cuban: Guys, you said
you're all about sales.
You had a sale.
You didn't close the sale.
Ladies,
I think we're all out.
Robert, if you come back in,
we'll do it.
25%. We'll do it right now.
O'Leary: Interesting.
You know what, though?
I'm not gonna do it.
Immigrant to immigrant.
No. You know what?
I -- I hear --
Oh! Boom goes the dynamite.
When somebody
makes you an offer,
a bird in the hand, right?
I made you a fair offer.
But, Robert,
isn't it smart --
if you know you're willing
to take it...
isn't it smart to look at all
your options and then decide?
...you should have
walked across, and we
could have done it.
Not always. Not always.
That's what a smart
businessperson would do.
O'Leary: Ladies...
we came in here to chat
with -- with all of you.
It's debatable.
We wanted to give you all
a fair chance.
...you've actually come into
the Lore of "Shark Tank."
You are going to become legend
because you had a deal
and you didn't close it.
You came into the Shark Tank,
poo-poo happened,
and you got a surprise ride.
[ laughs ]
You've got to turn around
and walk into the sunset.
Greiner:
Good luck, you guys.
It's over.
Thank you.
Thanks. Thanks, everyone.
Herjavec: Good luck.
Thank you.
Robert pulling away
at the end
is almost a blessing
in disguise.
It showed how serious
or not serious he was
about our business.
That's hilarious.
They talked themselves
out of a deal.
You know what? It happens.
It was their deal to lose.